dies ist die geschichte eines mädchens
das einfach nur ein video machen wollte
wie auch immer sie wollte ein video
drehen
und wusste nicht worauf sie sich
einlässt
hey leute hier ist wieder eure marne und
heute mit einem video auf dass ganz
viele gewartet haben und zwar ein neues
warne wilson bedingt da heute dachte ich
mir dass wir mal ganz tief nach unser
frau suchen sie rausholen und anfangen
zu häkeln in ihrem jugendlichem
leichtsinn kaufte sie sich ein headset
ich hab mal gehäkelt aber nie so
wirklich dabei konnte sie gar nicht
heben
das musste sich schnell lernen und
gucken wie es wird warum zwinge ich ganz
gut mein letztes jahr betrug
zunächst schien alles gut silas die
anleitung und dann begann das chaos
wirklich orientiere mich an den bildern
vom text verstehe ich gar nicht
zwar zweifelte an dieser anleitung dass
sie wollte nicht aufhören denn ihre
zuschauer wollten sehen wie sie diesen
kleinen süßen cupcake häkelt doch das
schicksal hat er andere pläne mit ihr
sie fing an zu trinken ein schluck nach
demnächst sie drehte durch na klar und
musste sich eingestehen dass sie nicht
regeln kann ihr fragt euch
wahrscheinlich was aus diesem mädchen
geworden ist einige sagen sie läuft
jetzt mit ihrer häkelnadel durch die
straßen sucht sich ihre opfer um in ein
polizei
andere wiederum sagen sie seien ihm
alkohol zerbrochen
doch ich weiß ganz genau ihr geist wird
hier irgendwo noch versucht eine bessere
anleitung
denn diese scheiß anleitung habt mich
nirgendwo hin gebracht diese faktisch
anleitung war so der letzte rotz ein
scheiß cupcake sieht aus wie ein
bootshaus kauft euch kein scheiß häkel
set denn diese fucking regelsätze sind
der absolute letzte mühle und ich will
nie wieder nie wieder über irgendwas
leute das war's für diese woche ich
hoffe euch jetzt gefallen
hier unten könnt ihr mich abonnieren
links und rechts von mir gibt's noch
mehr videos ihr euch anschauen könnt
falls ich das schon nicht genug war und
wir sehen uns dann schaut